[Music]
the hydrant Club has been a dog training
facility located in downtown Las Vegas
for the last nine years but the owner
says she can no longer compromise safety
to continue the vision that entrepreneur
Tony Shea once had for this area nine
years ago today
I stood right here
and announced the opening of this park
it's a full circle for hydrogen club
owner Kathy Brooks Brooks on delay
entrepreneur Tony Shay met in 2012 when
they decided to open the private dog
boarding and training facility as part
of the downtown project this was a dream
that I didn't know that I had
that
the blessing that was Tony Shea giving
the downtown area a new vision from
crime and grime to thriving businesses
he would walk by and there would be this
Oasis that gave everyone a sense of calm
and peace in the middle of Fremont
Street but broke said recently the
homeless have taken over making it
nearly impossible to get through her day
safely I've had rocks thrown at my head
I've been spat on I had someone throw a
drink at the fence at me but the last
straw was during an overnight shift at
the facility about 10 10 15 I'm awakened
to the sound of gunfire right outside
the wall against which my head is
resting just this weekend someone broke
off their doorknob I have clients who
stopped coming down here they're like I
don't feel safe downtown anymore
ultimately Brooks wasn't sure she was
safe anymore which meant she couldn't
jeopardize the safety of the dogs the
hydrant Club will close its doors on
December 31st until then it will remain
open every single day so its members can
continue playing and say goodbye to
their friend friends Victoria Saha 8
News Now